Sydney Crosby and Joe Peli at Center Ice a face
off on Fifth Avenue and underway here for the pens
of the Stars thanks for being with us on Sports
Net Pittsburgh M elovich out of his net jams it
into his own Zone on the near side picked off
by the stars and Jake Kel intercepts and sends
Crosby through Center ahead to rust over the line
he'll set her in front for Crosby who just missed
it driving the cage and what a great back check
almost in a way to stay with Crosby was heining
Toyota Grand Highlander lines are on the top of
your screen ice get in such a smooth skater was
able to stay with Crosby on that back Postell
wires one back in on ater who makes the sa
card Rael now counting that 11 shots on goal over
his last six plus periods of hockey like Sullivan
saying this morning the goals will come we
know he can rip it he's played pretty well
I think he just hasn't been able to get some
production but done a lot of the little things
that have made that line fairly successful Denny
dadonov in the attacking end for Dallas whips It
Wide it comes back to the point for ESS Lindell
his snapshot deflected by ban and it fluttered
through the blue paint looking for a Avenue he
finds Malin twisting and turning cross ice for
Crosby looking in front bounces back to Carlson
across Marin jams it save AER here's that Malin
shot also just getting a piece ainger once again
just enough to get piece of it gel was hunting
net front Crosby back in across shooting is rust
and a save made by AER moving left to right and
keeping it scoreless just controlled he gets
across no rebound great execution on Entry by
the Penguins right there H in the first year of
an 8-year 67.6 million deal that's nice here's a
chance in front and a great stop by ainger point
blank on Elli and Crosby on the draw they had
some battles think back to that 2016 Stanley Cup
Final lot of menacing moments between those two
in the faceof dot here's a chance crossby
ahead for kensel he'll hold it in front R
scores TI Tac Toe the three men up top
combined and Russ slams it home for a
one- nothing lead at their own Blue Line
right there just a good stick by Laten to
break it up and then a beautiful bump
pass off the wall out of the zone and
timing and precision look at that play
by gensel if you're going to stop this
goenda piece of pucks you've got to freeze
them with something and gel does a great
job with a fake shot hang on to it a little
longer as you can see Harley I don't know if
we'll expect too much offense from him but
the physicality in the dzone is what we're
looking for with him penguins have a minute
and 54 seconds of Power Play Time as we get
back underway to begin in this second period
Pittsburgh in front by a score of one nothing
Alice able to Rattle that one all the way back
down for the Penguin's perspective they hold
steady in the first period just two goals
against all year in the first frame that's
the second fewest in the NHL the Islanders with
one here's a chance short-handed by the star as
foxa put that wide delovic for leang ah head to
Riley Smith gallops over the attacking line for
Rael back to Smith towards the net a shot
is stopped by ainger it is dug free by the
Stars Marchman though unable to get a grip on
it Eller does and he'll skate through Center
chance short-handed here Lars Eller down the
right wing shoots he at the crossbar he's got
it here as he flips it down ice no points in 12
career games against the Pittsburgh Penguins for
Lindell pressuring here and a save by the delovic
another opportunity it's tucked in Jason Robertson
wouldn't give up and it's 1-1 we just talked
about him on the power play with a good shot
off the flank maybe a little turnover by Gino
at the offensive blue line and they come back
the other way off of a nothing play it felt like
turned into something right there a one battle
down low and it ended up on the wrong player
stick 46 goals last year for Jason Robertson
he's a 24y old another one of their young core
guys but Carlson Works through the check of
Dandrea dumps it back down to the attacking end
zahna drops it for ell his cross ice pass picked
up thrown on goal by o Conor and somehow it stays
out under the leg of ottinger Pon was like Carlson
there spinning around like a top Tyler Sean he's
got some moves in the attacking end leaned on by
Pon hands it off Harley shot is stopped put
towards the net and jabed in and Genny danov
deep in the blue paint puts it in and Dallas
takes the lead late in the second off a great
opportunity Josh at one end delay right here
s does a good job look at the Stick of petson
just going stick on Puck able to fend it off and
Harley just throws it towards the net and they've
got bodies there they're in the crease maybe
blocking movich to get over and try to Coral
that rebound as a puck was just kind of laying
around in front and Duane did a good job just
to here the guys talking at the intermission
about getting that kind of element into this
lineup they wait to hear more from the Penguins
on how he's doing rosby able to knock it away
but stolen back by Robertson a tuck attemp the
top the crease the delich alert and making a
huge stop here early in the third good for for
check there by Robertson to free that puck up
and he kind of made a read everyone thought
he was going to pass it as he just kind of
stepped right out front of the net with
his reach and speed almost able to elude
the pad of galovich wow what a play slides to
knock it away a chance for Dallas and Harley
scores Penguins all out of sorts and Thomas Harley
the defenseman with his first of the year and the
Stars extend their lead to 3-1 oh boy the skate
and then it just kind of Puck is just bobbling and
bimbling bobbling around M elovich made a split
second decision to R out at the Pucket and it's
just chaos just chaos Josh Harley walks into
a nice pass on a platter from Pavel here's nto
can't quite get away from Wy Johnson it's taken
away by Ben he turns it over aari with some space
Wier good save oer Lindell Scoops it back to the
penguin zone swatted out by Graves intercepted
by Ben down low it's Johnson backhander n
delovic stopped it where is it it's in the
goal it bounced off the delovic and in and Dallas
has added another one it's 4-1 Stars Brian Russ
hands but then it's just the puck is shot up the
wall doesn't get all the way out as Ben came onto
it and it's just a download play to Wyatt Johnson
another good young player for this Dallas Stars
team and just kind of hanging around there that
behind the net reviewing the players determined
that puck did cross the goal and therefore we have
a goal so it will count Wyatt Johnson following up
a career-high three-point effort against the
Philadelphia Flyers and a win for the stars
on Saturday has a goal in this one regains
possession hockin P for danov he's one of the
Stars goal scorers tonight picked up by Duane
to the net shot and a save made by NAD delovic
back for ay Malin Penguins will practice
tomorrow so it'll be interesting to see
what Mike Sullivan does with this lineup
as a chance in front for Smith he knocked
aside by oer that was a horn off a four
check again he gets after and you can see
why he got elevated up to this malan line
the seconds tick off the clock but pretty
nifty hands right there by Riley Smith on that
chance Ryan Graves carries the puck out of his
own end final seconds winding down here he'll
dump it down to the Dallas Zone and the Dallas
star hand the Penguins their third straight
loss 4-1 the final here at PPG Paints Arena